oh ich willkommen hier heute zu einem
neuen video auf meinem kanal und zwar zu
einem weiteren video der gugl play game
on kampagne im rahmen dieser kampagne
spielen jude und ich verschiedene
spieler aus dem google placed on wir
haben unter anderem schon eine rennspiel
gespielt 718 cayman s lesen und wir
haben schon eine telefon challenge
gemacht wir haben schon zins gespielt so
siehst du aus direkt oder du hast deinen
tod und den tod seiner tochter auf dem
gewissen
heute spielt er allerdings sein spiel
das auf den ersten blick gar nicht so
richtig aussieht wie ein spiel
allerdings bei juden mich eine sehr
brisante challenge darstellen könnte und
zwar heißt die app design haben man kann
hier ganz einfach vorhandene räume
designen oder auch neue räume im ihnen
die innen einrichten lassen mit neuen
stühlen mit neuen sofas mit einem neuen
tisch da vorne top designer ist einfach
ein hund er heftige sachen eingerichtet
die täglich wechselnden challenges von
beispielsweise eigentumswohnungen in
berlin oder irgendwelchen villen in los
angeles wie man dann die seine muss
einem für personen die beispielsweise
mal irgendeine bankberaterin sind oder
meinen schauspielern die haben uns
verschiedene wünsche ich allen stellen
und ich uns heute allerdings stellen
werden ist dass wir uns beide den
gleichen raum aussuchen und beide für
uns das beste geschmackliche design will
die west was mein und ja wir haben uns
hier für die challenge auto im süden
entschieden das ist ein schlafzimmer in
north carolina und die aufgabe ist
mobiler ein schlafzimmer im
traditionellen stil für das reizende
chateau einer autoren also juli fängt
jetzt hier an mit ihrem raum
als erstes kümmern sie sich um das bett
das jahr mit schon im besitz das ist
dass sie oder du kannst auch ein anderes
bett kaufen wird ist ja für dich auch
mit das wichtigste eine wohnung in der
tat während liga weiter ihr zimmer
design kann ich euch ja kurz darauf
diese challenge gekommen sind wir sagen
auch das spiel gekommen sind also wie
man als gesagt das ist teil der google
play game und kampagnen der kampagne
spielen wir halt verschiedene spiele und
betteln uns daran challenges gegen
andere juli und ich gekommen weil ich
glaube man sich auch schon in den videos
ich achte selber sehr auf einrichtungen
also hier jetzt nicht mit den beiden
tischen ist immer noch nicht warum ich
die letztens gekauft haben aber so
allgemein auch so ein clean ist
schlichtes design achte ja okay hier
stehen jetzt pakete und jule und
besonders mir ist es halt wirklich
wichtig dass in der wohnung gar nicht
aufgeräumt uns ist wichtig dass alles
irgendwie weg in das ladekabel schon
immer so in der luft das hier ist
tatsächlich die einzige echte pflanze
meiner wohnung also eigentlich ist die
ganze wohnung kompletter sauerstoff auf
jeden fall haben uns gedacht ist diese
design challenge mw errichtet das immer
besser möbliert das besser das ist
eigentlich ganz gut zu uns passen würde
wenn man ja auch früher oder später ein
eigenes haus einzieht und dass da alles
neu und frisch machen also das hier ist
jetzt julis final eingerichtete zimmer
für die buchautorin aus north carolina
was hast du dir denn dabei gedacht
[Musik]
ja ja mit so papierrollen dorf
ein passendes weiß ist so falsch als
julia hat auf jeden fall einfach ein
sehr sehr schlichten weißen ton genommen
und jetzt richte ich das ganze mache
eben ein 2000 jahre später weitere jahre
sind vergangen lieben freund ich habe es
jetzt auch endlich mal geschafft mein
zimmer hier fertig einzurichten
so sieht das bei mir aus also ich zeige
euch jetzt mal eben hier eine
gegenüberstellung von links meinem
zimmer und rechts julis zimmer und dass
ich mir hierbei ganz einfach gedacht
habe ist es ist natürlich ein zimmer
vereine roman autorin die verbringt
locker viel zeit im bett und auf viel
zeit beim lesen deswegen habe ich mir da
ich so einen gemütlichen sessel stellte
sich relativ klein aus aber der war
relativ teuer sogar ich habe mich
allgemeinen auch die jule für einen sehr
schlichten weißen stil entschieden
ich habe hier so ein bisschen akzente
gesetzt durch dieses etwas andere
pflanzen gestrickter vorne aber ich
denke wenn sie liest hat sie locker
gerne so ein bisschen geborgenheit eine
ahnung es ist ein verdammtes spiel und
eine virtuelle person der weg gemacht
haben
hier nochmal die beiden räume
eingeblendet also wie ich den raum
designt haben und wieder den raum gesagt
hat wir haben beide gleich viel geld
ausgegeben also von dieser
ingame-währung von diesen diamanten für
die möbel benutzt haben und ihr könnt
jetzt hier oben über eine umfrage
abstimmen wer eurer meinung nach also
sei alles nur geschmackssache aber
während die triple
wir befinden uns jetzt hier auch im auto
meine lieben freunde an der seite findet
ihr ein weiteres video der kampagne
verlinkt und zwar das video wohl und ich
ein horrorspiel auf unserem handy
gespielt haben und dort findet ihr auch
mal das logo der app die wir heute
gespielt haben eingeblendet und über
dieses logo könnt ihr euch direkt selber
die app runterladen